voilà nous nous rendons tout de suite à
cognac pour le 7ème festival de cognac
le festival du film policier
on nous attend celui que vous venez de
reconnaître sur votre écran c'est
monsieur glenn ford le festival lui rend
un hommage particulier avec la
projection de quatre de ses filles mais
il en a tourné beaucoup d'autres et
notamment il en a tourné en france
bonjour monsieur gars de forme très bien
comment allez vous je crois savoir que
vous aimez bien notre pays et vous avez
vous avez travaillé souvent chez léo
mais écoutez j'ai fait cinq films en
france dont dame ancienne beaucoup la
france et j'aimerais bien faire en corse
un contre-feu aussi j'aime beaucoup la
façon dont le travail en france et je
pense que vous faites du travail très
très bon dans le cinéma
je ne voudrais pas donner les noms de
personnes avec qui j'aime bien
travailler ici mais par exemple j'ai
travaillé au victory studio à nice un
très très beau studio des gens très très
agréable mais studios de la victorine
c'est vrai il ya une différence
vous estimez qu'il ya une différence
entre la façon dont on travaille en
france et la façon dont on travaille
chez vos états unis absolument oui il ya
une grosse différence
on n a pas la même pression aussi
lorsque je travaillais aux états unis on
exerce surtout dépression est absolument
incroyable il faut travailler pendant
cinq jours dans la semaine
alors que le régime de travail ici en
france c'est totalement différent nous
fait par exemple une demi-journée
travail et puis ensuite j'avais cinq
jours de repos pour prenais beaucoup
plus votre temps vous avez vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous presser alors que aux
états unis donc qu'il existe cette
pression comme ce mot disait michel
pascal michel je crois mais celui qui
vous a rendu célèbres vous avez un
souvenir l'autre partenaire écouté pas
seulement un film que vous voyez mais
vous oubliez un petit peu l'histoire
vraie de deux personnes la relation
entre deux personnes et nous nous sommes
fait de traiter les amis et un ouais
c'est moi alors écoutez je vous propose
de faire un petit flashback qui on va
regarder un exemple un court extrait de
gildas world
ok non c'est pas la meilleure
la scène comme aurait pu éclairer cette
scène là a commencé avec rita qui était
également sur les banques était si
furieux est ce qu elle me donnait une
mort et puis ensuite elle s'est effondré
sur le sol mais la seine ne s'est pas
tout à fait la même chose parce que là
il l'a déjà donc qui a été arraché par
ce que vous lui donner une claque dont
c'est pas tout à fait la même extrait
qu'on aurait plus là on va on va
s'interrompre jeudi pour l'instant
michel parce que john ford
on le retrouvera cet après midi sur
antenne 2 avec d'autres invités
prestigieux de ce festival du film
policier de cognac dans l'émission
faites comme chez vous c'est à 15h30
vous avez donc le temps de déjeuner
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bon séjour en france